c'est vrai qu'on a tous été vraiment
meurtri de voir ce qui s'est passé à
samedi quelle a été votre réaction à
vous quand vous avez vu ces images
intolérable déjà dans un premier temps
c'est sûr que on voit les
sapeurs-pompiers donc là ce sont les
collègues militaires de la brigade des
sapeurs pompiers de paris qui sont
engagés par rapport aux manifestations
que connaît paris évidemment depuis
quelques temps on voit effectivement de
la lâcheté on voit effectivement un acte
qui est complètement
on va dire inappropriée par rapport à
l'action des secours il faut savoir
quand même que les sapeurs pompiers
aujourd'hui à raison de deux cent
cinquante trois mille agents qu'ils
soient hommes femmes sapeurs-pompiers
volontaires ou professionnels
aujourd'hui ils font des interventions
pour venir protéger se courir et sauter
opérationnel mais en aucun cas on est là
pour se faire agresser se faire tabasser
parfois j'ai envie de le dire aussi
en aucun cas on est là pour recevoir des
coups de machette des coups de couteau
comme on a pu le constater
et aujourd'hui il est fort fort de quoi
il se confie non malheureusement et vous
voyez que aujourd'hui les procédures
font qu'aujourd'hui les sapeurs pompiers
sont partis en intervention avec la
fille de précaution possible donc on les
voit même avec la visière baissée c'est
aussi pour garder une certaine anonymat
donc on est dans ce respect là aussi et
donc à partir de là tout ce contenu
c'est qu'on espère c'est qu'on voit là
c'est des images convoyage en avant de
plus en plus on voit des pompiers se
faire attaquer se faire molester
est-ce que ça devient de plus en plus
compliqué d'intervenir ça devient de
plus en couple et plus en plus compliqué
dans tous les endroits et dans tous les
domaines
aujourd'hui les sapeurs pompiers à 3400
euros prise par an sont victimes d
agressions 3410 c'est à dire que quand
vous partez en intervention maintenant
non seulement vous avez l'angoissent 2
ce qui va ce qui va se passer parce que
c'est un peu ce que c'est quelqu'un de
rire en détresse et en plus elle envoie
ce faire et c'est surtout la
compréhension on est là pour venir
secourir et sauvés parfois des victimes
et puis d'un seul coup il ya une
rébellion général je vous rappelle aussi
que le 26 décembre donc quelque part le
lendemain des fêtes de noël dans le
vaucluse
vous avez trois sapeurs pompiers qui
venait de se faire tirer dessus par
quelqu'un vers qui vont porter secours
et vers qui on allait porter secours
mais au delà de deux de ces images qui
sont intolérables et inacceptables
il faut bien qu'on prend en compte que
quelque part sont effectivement les
sapeurs pompiers qui parfois sont
blessés eux
mais qui derrière ne peuvent plus
poursuivre leur engagement parce qu'on
parle de pompiers volontaires qui sont à
80%
l'effectif global des 253 me sapeurs
pompiers de france et au delà de ça ça
veut dire que derrière il faut peut pas
reprendre son métier son activité
personnelle ne peut pas retourner
correctement dans ses classes en avoir
ce poids sur la tête et au niveau des
pompiers professionnels c'est plus de
1400 jours d'arrêt sur une seule année
donc c'est quand même énorme parce que
derrière il faut rétablir les ressources
mais ça va bien plus loin que ça ça va
au-delà haute idée des véhicules les
véhicules de sapeurs-pompiers bien
souvent ils sont pris pour cible et ses
véhicules dès lors qu'ils sont abîmés
touché ses seins véhicules en moins pour
porter secours
donc dès lors qu'est ce qui se passe
parce que ça aujourd'hui quand vous
appuyez sur un bouton vous appuyez 112
vous savez pas ce qui se passe derrière
qu'est ce qui se passe tout simplement
qu'il faut mettre le véhicule de côté
faire appel un autre véhicule
un peu plus loin et du coup le petit
village c'est à côté mais ce tous deux
mis de secours
bien sûr quelque part quand il ya une
action comme celle ci c'est quelque part
c'est tout le système social et de
protection de sauvetage qui s'effondre